antoine griezmann au fc barcelone les
rumeurs selon lesquelles lionel messi
serait en froid avec le joueur se
confirme et les preuves s'accumulent
notamment sur le terrain c'est l'été
dernier qu'antoine griezmann intégrer le
club mythique
au cours des premières semaines tout
semblait aller pour le mieux le champion
du monde n'hésitant pas à partager sa
grande joie de pouvoir jouer aux côtés
de la légende lionel messi je m'inspire
de lui on boit le map et ensemble nous
sommes tous les deux des bons garçons
mais si lionel messi n'a jamais renvoyé
la balle à griezmann concernant ces
attentions là il semble en être de même
depuis quinze jours sur le terrain à
chaque fois mais s'ils ignorent et
pénalise de façon de plus en plus
évident que le français
il ya encore lors du match qui opposait
l'équipe espagnole au slavia prague en
ligue des champions alors qu'à deux
reprises antoine griezmann était en
bonne position pour marquer lionel messi
a préféré l'ignorer
[Musique]
un comportement individualiste qui
mènera le fc barcelone au match nul sur
d'autres images on voit que les deux
joueurs ne sont pas très proche
hors du terrain non plus et depuis la
rentrée ces déclarations d'amour à
lionel messi antoine griezmann semble
s'être quelque peu ravisé ce n'est pas
quelqu'un qui parle beaucoup et moi non
plus donc la communication est difficile
entre nous mais que se passe-t-il dans
les vestiaires du barça pourquoi lionel
messi semble en vouloir à griezmann un
mystère qui ne devrait plus tarder à
tomber
[Musique]
et donc apparemment grise où sera un
petit peu mis de côté par à leo messi
alors c'est vrai que c'était pendant le
match contre le slavia prague en ligue
des champions le mec il était tout seul
même isabelle elle aurait pu marquer
cette audition mais le gag lui fait pas
la passe c'est antoine griezmann c'est
une bombe
mais la suit la balle
on appelait à rabat le
[Musique]
c'est la main
de meuf entre aa
c'est un truc de ouf j'ai déjà la gueule
avant qu'il arrive au barça parce qu'il
a peur il a peur il n'aime pas la
concurrence
le spécialiste du foot qui dit c'est une
faute professionnelle
et comme si lui il avait une cabine d'uv
libre il l'aimé l'apprenez départ
[Rires]